hey Vsauce there's my name is Danielle
and I'm back today to tell you some
games that your girl will play with you
and she might actually like it now one
of my most recommended games to get your
girlfriend to play with you in payroll
or food halo 3 is a really really simple
controlled first-person shooter for Xbox
360 the reasons that I personally think
that a girl would like this game is
because it's a first-person shooter so
it's legit they don't feel like you're
dumbing your gaming down for them it has
objectives so even if you're not
necessarily great at pointing and aiming
and shooting you can play a flag game
with your girl and you guys could work
together as a team to go get the flag
and capture it and you can win the game
without her being able to play
whatsoever I also really like halo 3
because it's not gory and and with the
lack of gravity it's not realistic so
you don't feel like creeped out by like
shooting people or anything another
great idea for a game that you can get
your girl to play with you and she would
actually like it would be the new Super
Mario Brothers from me and this takes
everyone's favorite video game as Super
Mario Brothers for the original NES it
was like the first game that everybody
plays everybody loved it if you don't
love Mario where aren't friends anymore
I'm so sorry another awesome game to get
your girl to play with you [ __ ] she'll
probably like it's geometry wars for
Xbox 360 you can download it right on
the arcade and the name itself sounds
like oh my gosh I'll never like this
game ever geometry but it actually has
nothing to do with math at all it's sort
of like asteroids II sort of not really
but kind of you play like this little
guy and he flies around and he's got
this little trail like rainbow color is
really awesome colors it's got really
awesome techno music it's an awesome
game for you to play with your
girlfriend especially if she's not a
gamer it only uses one joystick on the
control that's it
another game I would recommend to try
out playing with your girl
for the Wii Sports was like the first we
game I ever tried my sister has a we I
don't wish I did what are you gonna do
but it was the first game that I ever
played on Wii and I thought it was a
blast I wanted to try every single game
I think that either tennis or baseball
was my favorite but I'm not sure they're
all fun it's got really cool multiplayer
so you can play against each other but
kind of together at the same time you're
up you're moving my arm was actually
showing the next day from playing the
tennis over and over and over again
and of course being that I am most I
couldn't not include world Warcraft on
this list world Warcraft is my favorite
video game to play by far
lots of girls playing it's not I mean I
think stereotypically it's a male
dominant game but there are a lot of
girls who play World of Warcraft
there's a lot of really pretty places in
world Warcraft the storylines are very
interesting question is fun in something
is fun it's fun being important being a
tank or a healer or a DPS it is just a
really really fun game and it is a great
game to play with your girlfriend you
can play if you're right next to each
other you can play if you're across the
country I am a huge fan I love it if you
play World of Warcraft definitely try to
get your girl brain to play with you
show her this video I am obsessed with
Warcraft I love it and I think it is
just I'm just a huge huge fan oh I
almost forgot the winners of this dart
practice guest passes our solar primal
and Trevor Bronson congratulations guys
I hope you have tons of fun random
wardrobe change for the win I hope you
enjoyed today's video guys and I hope
that you get lucky and getting your girl
the game with you if you want to know
more about how I became a gamer check
out this link right here it'll bring you
to a video on my channel that's on that
exact topic in the meantime go make sure
you check out all the vsauce videos
within the next seven days because we're
gonna be hiding a picture of michaels
cats lucy in one of the videos and the
first person to correctly identify in
which video and in what timeslot lucy
appears it's going to win a top secret
prize and everyone knows that top secret
means awesome thanks for tuning in guys
remember to comment thumbs
up and subscribe and we'll see you soon
Stanley nope Leroy no Leroy nope
bad cat naughty cat bad naughty we don't
do that that's naughty
Leroy you're doing it again I'm sitting
right here watching you can you go Leroy
don't chew on my notebook Leroy Leroy
Jenkins Co you're you're coming towards
my hand
Leroy this is that's the opposite of go
alright sit over there and be good
[Music]